all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
back with you again today on a busy day
of hanging out super excited I have a
special guest new friend of the YouTube
channel Lilith Bullock who wrote to me
with some questions she's doing for a
mash-up of experts to talk about social
media and I said I love it I want to
help how about we do it as a YouTube
interview so you can ask me your
questions and also tell I believe the
issue a little bit more about what
you're all about and provide some value
there too so welcome aboard is this your
first hangout it's the first thing on my
channel if you've done hanging here No
thank you so much it's great to be here
and I feel a big fan of yours for very
long time so it's a huge honor to be on
your show as well but yeah it's cool
I've done the Google Hangouts but it's
all changed now isn't it it's all now a
YouTube live event so yeah this is my
personal all right
I love it I love will welcome aboard I'm
going to get to your questions but
before that can you give the audience
just a little bit of context who you are
what you're all about
yes sure Simon is he like Alec I'm based
in the UK I'm I have a block
comp and I work with clients from
startups right through to entrepreneurs
SMEs and large corporates ultimately
helping them generate more traffic more
brand awareness more leads and
converting them into sales so yes that's
what I do
I specialize in implements of outreach
and content creation I'm also a speaker
and I just arrived in the early hours
back from Dublin this morning's I've got
a few lines here today so yeah vehicle
over the world and chat about on my mark
good I love the sign behind you there if
your dreams don't scare you they're not
I forget you can see they just fit in
the frame over here my shoulder just
fits there so I like it I like I like
seeing people's environments and what
they're doing it's fun yeah
you know I'm so nosey I love it I'm very
caring about other people but really I'm
just all right well you have a couple
questions I don't know what they are and
I asked on purpose not to know so I'm
excited what do we got we're talking
social media buy first of all thank you
so much so I'm creating a roundup post
for a very cool social media marketing
tool called Agora post and they work
presently with the SME market and I'm
reaching out to experts like yourself
you've got twenty others on board as
well so it wouldn't be the same not
having you included so my questions are
and be brutally honest okay so what do
you think is the main feature missing
from social media management tools today
I think the biggest thing so I I if I
look at my where I spend my social media
time it's a lot on YouTube YouTube
number one Twitter number two Facebook
number three if I'm looking at YouTube
the biggest thing that I that I'm
missing is the ability to easily find
comments that have not been responded to
I've been I'm obsessed with making sure
that people get responses to comments
yeah and and everybody says that at the
start in his funds and when you're
getting like two comments a day it's
easy to do or if you're getting two
tweets a day it's easy to do but it's
when you grow and you scale you know
what getting hundreds of comments a day
and I want to make sure that those are
being responded to whether it's me or my
team my team will respond to a lot of
them and pull out the ones that they
feel I need to see so an example some of
them might be hey I want you to do it
can you please do a top ten requests on
JK rowling or Oprah Winfrey or whoever
it is I don't need to see that one it
just goes to my team and they can add it
to the list of people that video on but
if they have a question I can't happen
can you you know help me with this
problem not you know we'll go to me
usually
there's no easy way to do it in YouTube
there's no easy way to find the comments
and be able to bring that out to your
team and so the way the way that we do
it is that my team has access to my
account so they can be managers and then
we have to get people different times of
the day so you do it from 9:00 to 10:00
a.m. and then you do it from 10:00 to
12:00 and that right so everybody has
their own time slot to be Lancer
comments in but it's gonna get to the
point where it's not manageable like
we'll have too many comments per hour
that it's just can't be managed by one
person anymore and there's no solution
doesn't exist so that's a huge pain
point that if you're on what's the name
of this what's the name of the social
company you're working with that is the
group oh so yes we are definitely a cool
include that in the article and it's
interesting because you know when you
scale up you need something that's not
only manageable but also like if you can
have tags so if you've got like a team
and you're using lots of people then you
want to be able to tag it so that for
example you can answer certain ones and
then different people in your team as
well so that you can see everything as
well all under one roof so yeah if that
company does anything close to this I
like let me sign up but I'll be the beta
tester we'll put it to work yeah it's
interesting a lot of people and social
as they build their channels they don't
you know it's the engagement that got
them to that level it's because I was so
involved with my community that that's
why they liked the post and leave
comments and it's a overwhelmingly
positive community that we have here
believe nation and that's how everybody
starts but almost everybody gives it up
at some point because it just becomes
it's not scalable but if you look at as
a business you know if you're running a
business if you're running the day
studio or you know coffee shop or
whatever you know you're not gonna be
able to handle at the beginning you
handle every customer yourself because
there's only a few coming in but as you
scale and grow
you have to build a team to be able to
you're not going to turn customers away
or so many emails your business you're
not going to write back so I see social
as that like I think it's rude not to
respond to somebody when they in time to
be able to leave a comment on your
channel and it's just kind of standard
practice that it'd be you'd be surprised
at how many people write back to say I
can't believe you actually roll back I'm
to respond is you know that is so true I
can ask testament you and what you're
trying to achieve here because there's
so many people is so hard I mean I
literally get in my own twist I mean I
got no any the numbers you've got but
that is becoming unmanageable and it's
really hard you know how do you do it
but I mean I rely on tools to do it but
YouTube is different obviously there is
a lack with managing and felonious yeah
on YouTube on Twitter I'd love to be
able to to segment out some of the most
common ones that may not be relevant
maybe with filters maybe it even exists
I just know how to use the tools is an
example like I get so many people who
like my videos okay it's a common on
each period there's a little Twitter
thing that they can click and it shares
it to their Twitter in that it always
says I liked this video from Evan
Carmichael so I get tagged in all of
these videos that people are liking and
it's great it's an honor to see that
people are sharing but it's not it's not
somebody reaching out to me to say hey
happen can you help me with this or I
have this opportunity or whatever
they're just sharing the video and so
I'd love to be able to like filter that
out or filter that off to something else
yeah is there there might be something I
think with Twitter there's a lot of
tools where you can do a lot more
filtering and tagging YouTube I mean I'm
wondering if it's the API it's down to
what I don't know I have to ask me the
Guru of personnel so if there's
something they're gonna be looking at so
yes that's really great a really good
insight okay so I kinda think it's sort
of a
this question but let me see if there's
anything else that you'd like to add to
it so what is the number one feature you
are looking for what in social media
manager is is that the number one
features or anything else the number one
feature for me is that YouTube ones that
I talked about you know and like I but
maybe a very specific case of how I use
social and I don't know how many people
I think I think youtubers who care about
their audience and are hiring a team to
now manage the comments it's super
relevant and valuable because nobody so
that's one of the biggest pain points in
my business right now and I'm afraid
because I can't scale without the right
tools
okay so let's height other tools are
watching this is heavy up if you built
this I desperately thank you so much
that's really super helpful and I'll
make sure that's all included in the
price I think so is that both the
questions I think that's a question that
was really super quick and easy so now I
can chat about got it okay so what are
your heavy into Twitter yeah what are
the to it so I use HootSuite as my main
tool I use it for Twitter wow that's a
big sigh that was a big no well I used
to love his it was mine um well I used
yes I was one of their first ones you
know and I think it's it's a good tool
it serves really well and I'm not
involved it's really old and I think
that there's a lot better ones available
now I think it's quite basic and then
reporting it sucks the reporting isn't
very very good at all so I think for
somebody with you who has such a huge
Twitter following and layers of
engagement I think you should use a
better tool what would that tool be what
do you recommend well I don't need
biased I like I mean I'm actually also
using a anyway but a corpus is good
sprout social have you had a post
planner as well
yes I think I was on it for a there
trial or a month or something like yeah
but why don't you experiment I think I
think you should try different ones and
see which ones especially the reporting
because I like the report for me it's
not just about managing it's about
actually seeing digging deeper and
seeing who are the people who are
sharing my stuff that most here are my
influences who my ambassadors all that
kind of thing rather than just replying
to people and seeing how many mentions I
like to look at the stats I want to see
how my Twitter's performing because I
can you know me it's not just about the
number of followers and followers it's
actually looking at how my engagement is
going this stagnating going art down you
know that sort of thing as well so you
find the reporting that's better using
the other tools oh my god yeah I mean
that's I think that's one of the things
I mean I think he'll see is a great tool
don't get me wrong I mean you know
they've got a lot Notley in the
marketplace um but I think the reason is
is because we're human beings were
naturally mazing so I don't know about
you but in England it's very rare that
people change their bank account and a
lot of people have been waiting for so
long and so people aren't changing and
they're stuck with it and I think they
see as change as a painful process as
well the reality is I mean I guess for
me because I'm quite savvy lots of
differentials as well but I'm quite
quicker you know getting familiar with
our tool works and maximizing it but I
think I think his suite had its place I
think it's good for certain people
I think the someone who's got such an
engaged community so much activity in
Ukraine is something a little bit more
but it gives you much more back yeah I
mean it's not honestly I guess is
because my focus is so much when you -
oh I'm a devourer the stats on YouTube
yeah
don't pay any attention to stats on
Twitter but you know in my
either a lot of your Twitter is crossing
into YouTube so maybe that a lot of your
YouTube that people come from Twitter
and that's something mine is a funny way
researching and seeing how they often
help one another great kind of work
alongside each other that's interesting
I never take on social no I like so one
thing that I thought one of the reasons
why I'm not on snapchat and we can have
a snapchat discussion on how much one of
the reasons I'm not on snapchat is the
growth within snapchat isn't there I
don't want to use another platform to
promote the platform so like if all of
my YouTube growth came from Twitter then
I'd rather be on Twitter and build that
up as opposed to using it so you know
the way to promote your snapchat is you
have to talk about it on your YouTube
and on your Twitter and on your Facebook
to get it going where there's no there's
no organic within yes say like hey go
check out Evans where my youtube channel
if I make more content more people are
gonna find it naturally organically
within YouTube and I don't have to do I
don't do any marketing at all of my
stuff I just make good stuff and it gets
out there and yes if you had great snaps
people will share it I guess but it's
it's not slower and there's no way
within the tool yet yes I'm sure it's
coming what are your thoughts by mindful
okay so I'll be really really honest
with you here say I am on snapshot I'm
rarely is it my daughter loves it she's
always doing these fun pictures I think
I only ever use it to take a photo
because the filters are so nice they
have much more flattering than the
normal photo I don't get the business
value um I think for me personally I get
so much value from Twitter and that
takes me so much time anyway I don't
physically have time to grow another
network and it will never grow to the
scale that my Twitter is I mean I get so
much you know I've got nearly no earlier
in your league
I've got nearly a hundred thousand
followers I get a ton of traffic a ton
of engagement from it and to replicate
that on snapchat will take me away from
that that's just simply not enough time
I think that is great fun I see a lot of
value for some people I'm not seeing a
huge ROI you know and I'm all about the
ROI there's a lot of people who do
social media because they have to do it
whereas for me it's you should do it if
that's where your audience is if that's
where your customers is that if that's
how you can monetize it then great but
not everybody's audience is there so I
look at it from a very different angle
but I mean you know I think some chef is
a lot of fun and I know some people who
are killing it on there and getting
great results but I also know a lot of
others who are just doing it for fun and
that's great I stay sound really boring
I decide to do the fun bit I prefer to
spend it on Twitter and on the live chat
who are asking if you could spell the
name of the tool that you use they
couldn't quite catch it I doubt it's a
food sweet yeah sure it's a core
repulsors IG IRA have a free trials well
Rishi cup TV and shine who are asking
about that there you go
towel towel Chris towel Chris is writing
in to ask is if this than that a good
tool been using it for a while but not
sure if I should continue oh yeah I know
if this is that it's a useful tool
they've got some really good recipes on
there that people can you know you could
share recipes I think it's good for some
things I think the challenge with it is
very automated and I don't think it's
good for certain tasks but if you're
looking to actually manage your social
media if you're looking to get reports
on your social media then you need to
use one or the other - but for
publishing it's very good I'm trying to
think how we use it one of the ways that
I use it
as my audience when International on my
YouTube videos with people chair and
tweet out there's a standard YouTube
message you know I liked a video a
YouTube video by Evan Carmichael and
then the title I and so I would just
respond to say hey thank you and then as
I started getting international ones I
would you know something in Japanese
right I would I would then go to Google
Translate and then looked up how do I
say thank you in Japanese and would
respond and then I got to the point
where it's just it's so many language is
overwhelming so I set up an if this and
that with a Twitter search so that if
anybody types in or if anybody tweets
that sentence in their language they'll
get a response from my account in their
language saying thank you I haven't I
don't even know I've talked about
besides maybe the first time you know
breaking breaking news yeah and then
people write back to say you know do you
speak Romanian everywhere I was like I
know it's just that it's a thing that I
wanted to recognize you in your language
because you shared it in your country
you know and it's just getting you even
more engagement and and you know people
will remember that because it's so rare
people just don't take the time to do
anything else we use it I think a lot of
the pictures that we use are the same on
Facebook in Twitter but we will post out
of our regular content but I don't think
we use it this and that I think we use a
blog plugin I think everything gets
posted to our blog yeah distributes it
to Google+ and Twitter and Facebook and
E that I'll be honest I don't use it for
that I started to but I found when I
published from there on Facebook it
doesn't always link so if I'm doing
third party
link so I prefer to my nearly it's a
pain on Facebook and also I noticed with
Facebook if you don't post manually the
reach drops they're very clever they
want you to do everything on mass and
the algorithms think Facebook's very
much anyway yeah and again it's back to
what you were talking about before about
ROI and leverage I accept
I'm just logging into my IFTTT see if I
have anything tricky there that I
haven't talked about
but its leverage like okay so yes it
will get less exposure if if I post it
automatic but my time to posted
automatic is zero in my time the post
manually is X so yeah way daily and I
think it depends what you're posting so
there's something for our post on a
regular basis and others are I'll be
like no it's important and I want to get
that person tagged as well
so you then on take more time but I'm
much less active on Facebook than
Twitter anyway yeah I used to I'm just
looking through it I have to go page at
a time because there's so many of the
translations like every language its own
thing
I don't know lots pages page is worse I
don't even know how many are on a page
and then x times four or five which one
get sees the mice can you see uh you can
it's something like again I'm not I'm
not the data guy I don't really pay yeah
I mean I'm sure the English one would be
the highest and then from there the
translations yeah I know
oh well post them to LinkedIn to sorry
so those pictures will go to LinkedIn
that's true if this than that I but I
think apart from that I don't I'm not a
heavy heavy user I used to when Google
Reader stopped coming out
I used to do it haven't if this and that
for all my feeds to go to something else
I don't know what this was anymore but I
still owe to pocket but I stopped doing
it it's a bit of fun and there's some
cool recipes on there but I found I
prefer to use one tool rather than
having lots of different tools lots of
different things it just becomes quite
overwhelming but I love the translation
thing I may have to borrow that idea I
can is very cool go for it
I love it yeah I think that's about it I
don't do a lot more automated automated
stuff there I what else we got
vital heartbeats make sure you guys give
this video a thumbs up thank you for the
love their violent repeats it's just a
lot of chatter so far look into see so
here's here's a question coming in
should use all social media accounts or
just one social media account like
picking picking the platform you do all
of them you do one how do you decide I
think ultimately it boils down to where
is your audience you know it's not about
copying everybody else and following the
crowd it's where your audience if you'll
predominately b2b and linked it could be
you know your number one platform I
I mean I'm such a fan of Twitter because
I find I love it and it's so easy to
draw a traffic from Twitter LinkedIn
takes a lot more time you know you've
got to be a lot more engaging you've got
to go to the groups and it's going to
take time to get results if that's what
your audience is you get some fantastic
results you know but I think it really
depends where your audience is how much
resources you have and the edge and also
trying to be a bit more creative at a
StumbleUpon
I love StumbleUpon as well and I think
what we're seeing with social media is
everything's becoming so noisy and it's
so much harder to get results from so I
prefer the other sounds crazy saying
this for them when there's still
millions of users on them but sam'l upon
degree if you're creating good content
then stumble upon
fantastic platform to leverage yeah I
think I think you have to find the one
first of all I don't think you should be
on everything I think I think you should
have the accounts I think you should
secure the name so that nobody else
takes your company name and your
personal name even if you never use it
just so that somebody's in squatting on
your name and then you have to go to you
know Evan Carmichael for you know
instead so you should get the name but I
don't think you can you can as a you
know entrepreneur be on all of them
effectively what I would try to do is
build up build it up to the point where
you can if you can prove Onarga why hire
somebody to then manage those things for
you if you're getting enough business
from Twitter then you can have something
to do it for you but I think I think for
the most for the biggest platforms the
audience is gonna be no matter what
you're selling you're gonna have an
audience there you know so yes LinkedIn
is gonna be more business and Pinterest
is gonna be more women and snapchat is
you know younger skew but if you're
looking at YouTube and Twitter and
Facebook you know everyone is there your
market is there whatever you sell your
market is there and you can have success
you know why why am I on YouTube when
you're on Twitter like I could have tons
of success on Twitter or tons of success
on Facebook I think you have to find the
thing that best suits your style because
the audience is going to be there for
all three of them I like video better
you know I like it better than writing
and now you can do Facebook video you
can do Twitter video but YouTube is
still the place for video what do you
think they're pushing it hard yeah I I
haven't done one myself I don't know if
you could do as a brand page I think you
came but I haven't I haven't done it as
a brand page I'm mostly annoyed when I
shows up in my feed from friends Here I
am on this boat or I can't I don't
like that's what the news feed is for I
don't need a notification that you're on
a boat and doing the video so that's why
we're doing it so much because nobody
gets notifications unless they do in
live videos there's so many people
caught onto that so they're doing a
video so they get in front of people I
think in time face that will remove that
notification Hey what I think well it's
Facebook live reaches more people doing
it the mass is more and I think they
will drop that notification thing and
then I can't then value what that will
drop dramatically because people just
won't see it I mean it's so hard for
people what's going on in your newsfeed
yeah so there's a follow up at me I
think I think the more social media
accounts the better and thoughts and and
again I think you should go and get the
accounts to keep the name but you can't
you can't do five things effectively
what's gonna happen is you're gonna do
all five you're gonna you gonna be
mediocre to all of them you gotta suck
any results anywhere where if you want
to get really good at something you have
to go in and get good at it right and so
for me it's you - yeah I have my
platform right I like I would rather do
an interview like we were supposed to
interview here I'm sure most people type
the response back to you like I don't
want to type response let's do it as a
video like I Excel is my platform I love
it right and so I will have I will reach
way more people by going all in on
YouTube then I will by splitting my time
up to three and doing a third on YouTube
and a third on Twitter and third on
yeah people spread themselves spin and
they do that with all their marketing
not just social media and they wonder
why they're not getting the results is
because you know there's only one of
them and they don't have a good support
network people to do it and they're
gonna struggle and it's I think it's one
of the biggest mistakes business owners
make in general on top of running the
business I think we spend more time when
I do more time marketing and doing all
of this i managing my social media and
everything and I do actually doing any
works yeah it's the same thing as if
you're if you're launching a new company
and you're launching running shoes and
you launch a hundred different pairs of
running shoes at the same time like
they're not going to be good all of them
people to follow you like why do I have
400,000 followers or subscribers on
YouTube
because you guys like the content
because I've done enough quantity to be
able to know how to create something
that's of quality I did the practice
right where if I was just posting random
stuff or it wasn't you know up to the
skill good you guys wouldn't be here you
wouldn't be following me and that's what
most people do they're posting crap just
populating a blog for the sake of it has
no value and they wonder why it's not
getting shared and also they just look
at the vanity metrics as well they don't
see the real engagement side of things
I'm passionate about this I guess
they're bringing it out they're bringing
it out of me oh well I think you should
make content that you want to show your
grandkids make content that you are
proud of making that you get inspired by
when you look at and not just is just
another another marketing I'm going to
spam out there and just blast the world
nobody's gonna follow you if you're just
pumping out coupon codes and and junk on
your stream nobody's going to follow you
right for creating great content
I'm create a lot of words written
content I should do more videos it's
something that maybe it's a female thing
I'm not comfortable with I don't know
but at that I enjoy it when it's with
somebody else but I think on my own it's
like oh but ya know I need to embrace it
but yeah I love Twitter and I get so
much from it it's kind of that'll take
me away from that but yeah but it's
working brilliant well I mean you're
I don't know that you should sell
yourself that sure you're getting a lot
of love in the comments and people
enjoying this this trick should being
you know your first time on this
platform but again it's doing the thing
like don't don't get into it because I
tell you to get into it right or
everybody watch don't get into YouTube
because Evan is success on YouTube right
you gotta [ __ ] maybe you're better at
writing and so you got to be on Twitter
putting your witty responses in or
creating blog posts and content if you
want to have success on YouTube you have
to enjoy making videos yes cuz that has
to come across and you've got to get
your passion to come across I mean you
can't there's no you can't hide you know
the cameras is it all just a mere so if
you're having a crap day and you're not
feeling great you know the cameras gonna
shake but you have to be changed all the
time so you do never work in your PJs on
anything like this this is this these
are my PJs this is a tune on me this is
maybe not the hat but if you're doing it
only for marketing then you're gonna
fail you won't have it you won't build a
huge channel say yeah Twitter if it's
only for marketing if you're only
putting up marketing stuff nobody cares
and we're gonna follow you you have to
create valuable interesting tweets and
actually engage in the conversation it's
very simple really when you think about
it now so many people still get it wrong
because they constantly I think people
are naturally very impatient they just
you know they want where that is now
they don't want to go through that
journey to get there there's a question
from Lee leave li-fi hope I pronounced
that okay for you how much time you
spend a day on your main social media
social medium which is Twitter so how
much time you spend it on Twitter it's a
question okay so it really varies what
I'm doing
but I dedicate every day at least 30
minutes sometimes it's an hour if I'm at
an event say yesterday I was speaking at
an event so it was a lot more because I
had a but generally I my to do this I
always budget 30 minutes minimum and
sometimes an hour so yeah yeah but
that's just Twitter then there's
Facebook IOC is Google fast I know we're
running out of time I was very much I
love Google past I have to say as well
but yeah so and then the others it say
on average at least an hour a day across
all of the platforms on sometimes two
hours depending on what you cool well
thank you for the interview and being
brave and coming on and sharing some
wisdom okay when is your not coming out
for people to check out I said I I've
got to write it up and include all your
fantastic insights gonna be super
helpful I'm so it will come out in the
next few weeks so on on let you know
what it is and then if you want you can
share it with with your great
subscribers as well and for people who
want to learn about you what's the
what's the best place to find you I
guess on your Twitter my Twitter is Lila
oh my website again look comments really
not yeah
apart from being able to pronounce my
name and spell it inside yeah I love
that
well thank you for joining us thank you
all you guys for watching continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
we'll see you soon thank you